Otacon snake are you okay I've been down
in every fire and I can't get this door
open
which door uh I'm on level 2b snake you
need to go back to level 2a and use the
key card to get in Otacon that room is
filled with poison gas you need the
peripheral crystals perineum crystals
press the select button to view your
items select button what are you talking
about Otakon I'm gonna die here you need
to find the gem of understanding but
akan press r2 to see if you have it ah
snake did I ever tell you the story of
how my father died it's about 25 minutes
long Annika there are too many of them
hi
Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes now
this is the new Metal Gear Solid game if
you want to call it that because there
is a bit of a controversy going on with
this game and I'm there talk to you guys
about it because I am a humongous Metal
Gear Solid fan I was extremely excited
to play this game I was at Walmart at
midnight because the game stopped near
me did not have him and not released for
whatever reason I had them dig it out of
a box the first Metal Gear Solid game
for PlayStation 1 is the game that made
me realize that video games can actually
be an art form the first time I beat
that game the very next day I beat it
again all in one sitting that's how much
I love that game it had such an impact
on me I was so into the character and
each subsequent game was also great and
if you're not initiated with the Metal
Gear Solid franchise basically what this
game is is a prologue of the upcoming
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain for
that reason a lot of fans are upset
because they buy a game they want to
play a long big 10 15 20 hour game where
they can have a lot of fun with it and
really get into the characters and what
this game basically is is it's probably
like the first two hours of the upcoming
Metal Gear Solid 5 now I'm assuming that
since fans have played this now that
when you actually get the phantom pain
you're not going to have to play it all
again there's probably a way that
they're going to tie it all in to each
other but basically what Hideo Kojima
the creator of the franchise said is
that he wanted to give fans an
opportunity to play a lot of this game
because we're all salivating for it and
so for that reason your person who isn't
really into Metal Gear Solid is going to
go pick up this game and think wow that
ended really fast and it didn't really
go anywhere what was that all about I
would say it took me about maybe 2 to 3
hours to beat the game there are still
some random little unlockables that I
can obtain that I haven't gotten yet but
for the most part it took about 2 to 3
hours and I had a great time with it why
is that because the gameplay is like
flawless the graphics are beautiful the
rendering the texturing everything about
it looks fantastic the stealth was great
it wasn't overwhelmingly difficult like
some Metal Gear Solid installments in
the past there were ways around certain
things that in the past were like so
daunting now one of the things that a
lot of people tweeted to me when I said
that I was buying it were oh you're
buying that glorified demo
basically I'm a humongous Metal Gear
Solid fan also the game is half priced
from your average ps4 game it cost
9999 yes is not a 59.99 game that being
said I think if you're not really a huge
fan of the male Gear Solid franchise and
you're just interested in seeing what
this looks like on a ps4 and what the
gameplay is like I would say wait till
there's a bit of a price drop or to get
it used I would say for like $15 to $20
that's a perfect price for this game for
me I'm fine with $30 because I'm a
humongous Metal Gear Solid fan and it's
kept me interested in video games as an
art form over the years and its
continued to bring me back and give me
great entertainment so I'm interested in
seeing where these characters go or
where they went in the past because this
game is a little bit different like that
that being said there is a major change
in this game that really kind of made me
feel sad David Hayter does not voice
this version of snake and it's
understandable because it's not like
Solid Snake you know so the voice
wouldn't be the exact same Kiefer
Sutherland voices him in this and he
doesn't do a bad job his voice work is
fine it's just that when I see that face
I expect Otto Kahn I cannot get into
level 27 mistake you're gonna have to
smoke a cigarette and use the perineum
gas and the key for level 27 be Otto
Kahn you're confusing me and I don't
know what you're talking about come on I
missed that voice and it's it I'm gonna
have to get used to it I guess one of
the cool new things about this game that
you cannot do in any of the other Metal
Gear Solid games is control vehicles
it's basically an open-world environment
if you see a truck you can drive it it's
all interactive with a player which is
really really cool the codec seems to be
gone as well it's like a radio
transmission that you just get as you
run around so that simplifies things a
bit too there's not much else to say
about this game basically you are at a
base trying to infiltrate and save a
couple prisoners and there's some other
missions in which you can do some
various things as well and certain
unlockables you can get and so for fans
of Metal Gear Solid I can see you really
enjoying this because I did it was so
cool to take control this character on a
next-gen system I had a lot of fun with
it so I'm going to do something a little
bit different here that I don't normally
do if you are not a Metal Gear Solid fan
and you are expecting a full complete
game this is about a 7 out of 10 for you
you might be kind of disappointed by the
fact that it ends and then there's
nothing else after it however it is
extremely fun to play the post couple of
hours and to get you into what will
eventually be
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain if
you are a Metal Gear Solid fan I would
give this an 8.5 out of 10 because it is
what you want to see on a next-gen
system you don't quite get into it as
much yet you're like I almost got into
the emotional thing and then it ends you
know what I mean and so for that reason
it's not really like a perfect game at
all in fact it's not a full game so I
can't give it a full rating I did have
one glitch while I played it and it
wasn't because of the system because
when I turned off the game the system
and the menu and everything worked fine
and I actually recorded that glitch and
I'll show it to you now
I don't know what that was but I had to
actually reset the game that only
happened one time but for the most part
I really enjoyed playing this because I
am a huge MGS fan if you're not though
and you're not initiated with the
franchise this might be a little strange
for you so guys let me know what your
thoughts are in the midle Gear Solid
series or this new game are you excited
for the phantom pain are you going to
get it on Xbox one or ps4 as always guys
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck menage